ich habe in den letzten wochen immer
wieder betont dass unser gemeinsames
ziel sein muss die ungeimpften zur
impfung zu bringen anstatt die kämpfen
einzuschenken
dort monate lange überzeugungsarbeit
trotz intensiver auch medialer kampagnen
trotz diskussionen mannigfaltigen den
medien ist es uns nicht gelungen genug
menschen davon zu überzeugen sich impfen
zu lassen
die maßnahmen die man den letzten wochen
gemeinsam aufheben der bundesregierung
getroffen haben insbesondere zweig und
bloggt für die ungeimpften ja sie haben
die impfbereitschaft erhöht das haben
wir gesehen einen bildern in den straßen
aber eben nicht in ausreichendem maß
lange zeit war es politischer konsens
dass wir in diesem land keinen keine
impfpflicht wollen
vista war der realität ins auge schauen
lange vielleicht zu lange bin ich und
auch andere davon ausgegangen dass wir
dass es möglich sein muss muss menschen
in österreich zu überzeugen und zu
überzeugen dass sie sich freiwillig
impfen lassen zu überzeugen dass sie
dies zu ihrem eigenen schutz zum schutz
wieder mit menschen ihre liebenden ihre
freunde und ihre arbeitskollegen tun
aber
wir haben wir müssen den realitäten
einfach ins auge schauen wir haben zu
viele politische kräfte auch in diesem
land die ganz vehement und massiv und
öffentlich dagegen ankämpfen das ist
verantwortungslos
das ist eigentlich ein attentat auf
unser gesundheitssystem
und aufgestachelt von diesen radikalen
impfgegnern von fadenscheinigen fake
news haben sich leider zu viele unter
uns nicht impfen lassen die konsequenz
daraus sind überfüllte intensivstationen
und
enormes menschliches leid und das kann
niemand von uns wollen wir haben bei uns
heute ist dieser gestern zu einem sehr
schwierigen beschluss durchgerungen zum
beschluss dass es sehr rasch jetzt eine
bundesweite impfpflicht in die wege
leiten diese soll bereits am ersten
februar nächsten jahres 2022
gelten
die
impfquote nachhaltig zu erhöhen und ich
glaube das sind wir uns alle einig die
impfquote nachhaltig zu erhöhen ist
unser einziger weg um aus diesem
teufelskreis von virus wellen und locker
und diskussionen endgültig raus zu
kommen wir wollen keine fünfte welle wir
wollen keine sechste und siebte welle
wir wollen diese diskussionen im
nächsten frühjahr und sommer nicht mehr
führen müssen und jahre müssen zur
kenntnis nehmen dass videos geht nicht
weg es bleibt und wir müssen lernen
damit umzugehen und die art und weise
wie damit lernen umzugehen ist die
impfung das ist unser ex ticket das ist
der wesentliche wellenbrecher
neben dieser mittelfristigen perspektive
bedarf es aber leider auch kurzfristiger
maßnahmen die bundesregierung die
landeshauptleute sind da überein
gekommen dass wir in anbetracht der
ernsten lage in anbetracht des
infektionsgeschehen es keine andere
möglichkeit sehen dass weitere
einschränkende maßnahmen für alle zu
verordnen zum schutz von uns allen zum
schutz unseres gesundheitssystems ab
montag für maximal 20 tage wird ein
bundesweiter lockdown gelten der nach
zehn tagen evaluiert wird er endet
automatisch spätestens am 13 dezember ab
diesem datum ab dem 13 dezember gilt für
geimpfte und genesene kein lockdown mehr
natürlich das sage ich auch gleich dazu
wird es in dieser phase sowie das
vielleicht schon in der vergangenheit
geübt haben wirtschafts hilfen für die
betroffenen branchen geben der
finanzminister wird noch heute das
entsprechend medial bekanntgeben ich
muss betonen diese entscheidung fällt
uns nicht leicht niemand von uns tut das
gerne aber und niemand von uns setzt
freiwillig schritte die die freiheit der
menschen einschränkt aber angesichts des
infektionsgeschehen es mit dem wir
konfrontiert sind nicht nur in
oberösterreich und salzburg die diesen
mutigen schritt bereits gesetzt haben
müssen solche maßnahmen setzen wir
tragen sie auf alle mit das ist ein
schulterschluss über parteigrenzen
hinweg das ist ein schulterschluss über
landesgrenzen hinweg und zwischen bund
und ländern der schmerz den ich
sage ganz offen wir haben genug
impfstoff in diesem land und ich habe
schon oft gesagt wir haben andere
regionen der welt die noch immer ringen
um ausreichend impfstoff wir haben bei
weitem genug und daher schmerzt es dass
überhaupt noch solche maßnahmen treffen
müssen dafür solche einschränkungen auch
überhaupt noch an denken müssen
meine damen und herren ist bewusst dass
wir den geimpften land kämpften menschen
in unserem land enorm viel abverlangen
sie müssen noch einmal einschränkungen
für maximal 20 tage auf sich nehmen weil
zu viele unter uns solidarisch gezeigt
haben bitte ich bitte sie alle um ihre
mithilfe machen sie mit tragen sie diese
maßnahme mit versuchen wir die kontakte
zu verringern maximal 20 tage lang damit
das weihnachtsfest für die geimpften und
geschützten gesichert ist damit wir dann
wieder ab dem 13 und soweit möglich
normales leben führen kann
ich sage der damen und herren liebe
österreicherinnen und österreicher die
vierte welle hat uns voll erwischt wir
sind fast täglich rekorde bei den
neuinfektionen wir hören die
alarmsignale aus den intensivstationen
wir hören die berichte von pflegerinnen
und trägern von ärztinnen und ärzten wir
haben menschen die an krebs verstorbene
angehörige betreuen es waren allein von
mittwoch auf donnerstag 55
es gibt viele gründe wie wir in diese
situation geraten sind wir haben eine zu
niedrige impfquote wir haben eine
hochinfektiöse variante die delta
variante und wir wissen dass der
impfschutz nach vier fünf sechs monaten
nachlässt
es gibt aber auch natürlich den
saisonalen effekt wir haben winter die
menschen halten sich wieder verstärkt in
ihren räumen auf was die verbreitung des
virus begünstigt
die maßnahmen mit denen wir darauf
reagiert haben die drei am arbeitsplatz
die zweige regelung in den allermeisten
bereichen haben zu einer verlangsamen
geführt aber die experten sagen uns das
wird nicht reichen
sowohl salzburg als auch aus österreich
das sind die beiden bundesländer die mit
der schwersten wähler zu kämpfen haben
haben bereits einen login angekündigt
vor diesem hintergrund sind wir als
bundesregierung klingt das gespräch mit
den landeshauptleuten gegangen und
werden notwendige verschärfungen und
eine gemeinsame entscheidung zu reden
ich betone das gemeinsame an dieser
stelle so explizit weil es in einer
krise wichtig ist dass es zwar
unterschiedliche standpunkte geben kann
die man auf einen nenner bringen muss
aber auch dann muss man gemeinsam an
einem strang ziehen
leider sind auch die us-bundesregierung
mancher stelle hinter unserem anspruch
zurückgeblieben ich möchte mich dafür
entschuldigen
umso wichtiger war es uns diese schwere
entscheidung geht es in seinem
dreiwöchigen wellenbrecher lockt dann
für ganz österreich gemeinsam zu treffen
und es ist uns schwer gefallen diese
entscheidung zu treffen ich bin jetzt
froh dass sie so getroffen worden ist
niemand will einen drucker und adaptern
ist das allerletzte mittel ein grobes
instrument das uns allen viel abverlangt
eindruck dann ist immer eine zumutung
aber es ist das verlässlichste
instrument das wir haben um diese vierte
wähler zu brechen und wenn wir gemeinsam
handeln wenn alle diese entscheidung
mittragen
dann wird dieser gemeinsame entbehrung
auch zum ziel führen wir werden die
zahlen unterbringen wir werden das
personal auf den intensivstationen
entlasten können wir werden
menschenleben retten können
ich möchte mich an dieser stelle bei den
landeshauptleuten und beim bundeskanzler
für diesen gemeinsamen schluss bedankten
es ist nicht leicht gefallen aber es
waren notwendig es ist keine populäre
entscheidung
aber sie war notwendig ab montag dem 22
november gilt folgendes
ganztägige ausgangsbedingungen für alle
personen in österreich
schule und kindergärten bleiben
grundsätzlich geöffnet
ausnahme gründe zum verlassen der
wohnung sind die bereits bekannten
abwendung von gefahren leben und
eigentum der konter notwendigen
grundbedürfnisse
berufliche zwecke und ausbildungszwecke
aufenthalt im freien zur körperlichen
und psychischen erholung und für
unaufschiebbare behördliche oder
gerichtliche wege
wo immer möglich soll auf home office
umgestellt werden außerdem wird die fbw
masken pflicht ausgeweitet sie gilt ab
montag in allen geschlossenen räumen und
am arbeitsplatz
außer es gibt sonst schutzvorrichtungen
nach endet diesen allgemeinen ob tanz
werden wir dann wieder zurück zum lockt
dann für geimpfte personen kern
die impfung schützt sie schützt uns
geschützt aber auch unsere mitmenschen
sie verringert das risiko sich
anzustecken im spital oder gar auf der
intensivstation zu landen und noch mehr
verringerte die chance auch tatsächlich
arkona zu sterben die impfung wird
darüber hinaus aber noch lange das
ticket für einen möglichst normalen
alltag sein den zweig das sage ich jetzt
sehr deutlich wird uns noch lange
begleiten wir haben uns daher nach
intensiven beratungen in der
bundesregierung und mit den
bundesländern
zwar darauf geeinigt dass es auch in der
aktuellen situation einschränkungen
braucht auch verdienste aber dies
zeitlich begrenzt für ungeschützte wird
es auch danach weitere schutzmaßnahmen
brauchen mit dem lockt dann brechen wir
die vierte welle
um die fünfte welle zu verhindern müssen
wir intern impfen impfen und deshalb
haben wir uns auch für eine impfpflicht
gemeinsam entschieden
sie haben das von mir schon oft gehört
und sie werden es noch oft von gehören
wir brauchen eine höhere
durchimpfungsrate
wenn wir da täglich diese pandemie
hinter uns lassen wollen ist unser
einziger weg aus der pandemie wir haben
mit anreizsystemen gearbeitet und jetzt
das hat auch wirkung gezeigt aber
schlicht nicht genug
daher hat sich die bundesregierung mit
den landeshauptleuten wie gesagt auf die
allgemeine pflicht verständigt diese
soll in den nächsten wochen gemeinsam
mit den sozialpartnern mit der
zivilgesellschaft und den betroffenen
gruppen erarbeitet werden ein erstes
gespräch mit den sozialpartnern hat
bereits gestern stattgefunden auch
zahlreiche verfassung touristinnen und
touristen haben sich mit diesem thema
bereits beschäftigt und sie ignorierten
signalisieren uns dass eine allgemeine
impfpflicht
im fall der krone schutzimpfung
verfassungsrechtlich legitim ist geister
auch und das möchte ich unterstreichen
ein ordentliches begutachtungsverfahren
ist uns dabei extrem wichtig dieser
prozess wird jetzt gestartet
die impfung ist unser einziger ausweg
heraus der pandemie die impfpflicht wird
uns langfristig helfen was es jetzt aber
braucht ist die dritte dosis der booster
schon hier haben wir in den vergangenen
tagen in den vergangenen zwei wochen
durch große fortschritte gemacht die
zahl der erste impfungen hat sich seit
einführung der 3g regelung am
arbeitsplatz und der zweijährigen
vervierfacht und mit unserem täglichen
fahrten führen wir die europäische
statistik derzeit an
das zeigt viele menschen wollen sich
schützen sie wollen mithelfen die welle
zu brechen und ich bedanke mich bei
allen die das bis jetzt gemacht haben
man sich impfen lassen
von den 15 trend gibt es wieder
schlangen danken die bundesländer hier
für die abwicklung und allen die in
denen im straßen arbeiten und über
schichten schieben um diesen antrag
überhaupt bewältigen zu können das bild
macht mir hoffnung
die auswirkung der gestiegenen
bereitschaft auf das infektionsgeschehen
werden wir bald beobachten können
wir möchten das jetzt und es werden noch
einfacher machen auch darauf haben wir
uns geeinigt wenn diese auffrischung
weil diese auffrischung so enorm wichtig
ist und weil wir uns inzwischen
ausreichend gewesen dazu haben wird das
nationale ins gremium seine empfehlung
wie folgt anpassen die dritte dosis bei
weg.de impfstoffen ist nach vier monaten
empfohlen die dritte dosis bei immerhin
einstufen nach vier monaten
möglich parallel dazu wird es eine
anpassung auch beim grünen passgeber
abschließend möchte ich noch einmal dazu
aufrufen lassen sie uns jetzt gemeinsam
an einem strang ziehen halten sie sich
die therapiemaßnahmen holen sie sich
ihre dritte dosis an ihren schutz wenn
sie noch nicht geimpft sind bitte machen
sie sich gleich einen termin aus nur
gemeinsam schaffen wir den weg aus
dieser pandemie
und meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
wir haben ein sehr dynamisches
infektionsgeschehen
ganz österreich und in ganz tirol
die zahlen gehen massiv nach oben
und die botschaft des medizinischen
personals
die botschaft der ärztin nun erste ist
eindeutig
wir müssen harte maßnahmen unternehmen
sonst kollabiert das gesundheitssystem
es sind all jene die in den spitälern
arbeiten schon an den grenzen ihrer
belastbarkeit
und auch diese leute brauchen eine
perspektive
damit sie auch noch kraft haben diese
wichtige aufgabe zu bewältigen
wir haben uns deshalb sehr lange
auseinandergesetzt
es war eine lange nacht und heute in der
früh und es ist wichtig das sind so
einer situation
bund und länder an einem strang ziehen
und ich bin froh darüber als derzeitiger
vorsitzender der
landeshauptleutekonferenz
dass wir eine einigung zwischen bund und
länder zustande gebracht haben dass wir
eine einigung somit haben zwischen svp
sp und grüne
mit ein zweites sagen so eine pandemie
kann man nur dann bewältigen
wenn die länder hier alles mittragen die
gesamte infrastruktur zur verfügung
stellen und alle damen und herren die im
einsatz sind zur verfügung stehen damit
dass alles möglich ist da passt aber
nicht nur die länder sondern auch die
städte und die gemeinden und da möchte
ich mich sehr herzlich bedanken was bis
jetzt alles schon passiert ist geschehen
ist und die bitte ist dass wir gemeinsam
nun diesen kraftakt über die bühne
bringen meine wichtigste botschaft ist
es wird die allgemeine impfpflicht geben
nur so kommen wir aus dem teufelskreis
heraus welle lockt dann welle und look
down er hat gestern schon gesagt und bei
den verhandlungen verlangt dass eine
impfpflicht eingeführt wird ich bin froh
darüber dass das passiert ist wir alle
haben gesagt früher ja es braucht keine
impfpflicht aber das problem ist wir
sind mit der durchimpfungsrate nicht
nach oben gekommen wir sind zu weit
unten damit wir diese panne wie
bewältigen können und deshalb ist aus
meiner sicht diese maßnahme dringend
notwendig zum lockdown bis 12 dezember
wie sie wissen war ich immer dagegen
ging einen look down
aber es war in den verhandlungen
notwendig dass wir auch zu dieser
massnahme greifen dass wir die
impfpflicht zustande gebracht haben das
ist nun eine notbremsung die hier
gemacht wird damit wir die pandemie
bewältigen können es handelt sich also
um einen kurzen befristeten look down
mit einem fixen ablaufdatum das ist der
zwölfte dezember
danach ist es aber auch so dass dieser
look down für ungeimpfte weiter gilt
diese drei wochen müssen wir nützen
wir müssen diese drei wochen nutzen dass
sie so viel wie möglich impfen lassen
wir werden die struktur herstellung es
ist aber auch die bitte an die
bundesregierung dass wir ausreichend
impfstoffe zur verfügung haben und wir
werden daher auch diese breite struktur
aufbauen mit den gemeinden und hier ist
dann die möglichkeit gegeben dass man
den ersten stich erhält den zweiten
stich aber ganz wichtig ist auch der
dritte und
ich bin darüber hinaus auch wo das nach
dem vorbild von wien und tirol ab dem 4
monat der dritte stich möglich ist ich
weiß meine damen und herren das sind
sehr harte entscheidungen die getroffen
wurden ich weiß dass es für manche
schwierig ist die einfach sorgen haben
was die impfung betrifft aber glauben
sie mir und alle ärztinnen und ärzte
bestätigen dass du diese sorgen
unbegründet sind nützen wir daher diese
drei wochen damit wir mit der
durchimpfungsrate weiterkommen damit wir
gemeinsam diese bande mit bewältigen
können das können nicht wir in der
bundesregierung oder in der
landesregierung in den städten und
gemeinden wir können das nur gemeinsam
mit der bevölkerung schaffen wenn wir
das tun dann haben wir die chance das
wären die fünfte welle vermeiden können
herzlichen dank
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler sehr
geehrter herr bundesminister meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir möchten am
beginn meiner kurzen ausführungen mich
ganz herzlich bei herrn landeshauptmann
platter bedanken der derzeit
vorsitzender der
landeshauptleutekonferenz
sehr koordinierend gewirkt hat auch
zwischen den bundesländern und möchte
mich auch für die gastfreundschaft hier
in tirol am achensee bedanken ich glaube
man kann sagen es war ein historisches
treffen der landeshauptleute gemeinsam
mit bundeskanzler und
gesundheitsminister weil wir eine
vereinbarung getroffen haben über die
parteigrenzen hinweg über die
bundesländergrenzen hinweg die manchen
von uns nicht leicht gefallen sind wohl
recht auf sagen eigentlich uns allen
nicht leicht gefallen sind aber wird
diese vereinbarung treffen in der
verantwortung der bevölkerung gegenüber
und es ist vieles gesagt worden ich
möchte vielleicht nur noch einmal
unterstreichen dass wir im wesentlichen
zwei zeit dimensionen mit dieser
vereinbarung abdecken eine kurz und
mittelfristige in richtung verhinderung
einer weiteren welle die auf uns
zukommen würde indem wir maßnahmen
setzen um das impfen voran zu teilen
dazu gehört dass wir den dritten stich
früher möglich machen wie das in einigen
bundesländern schon der fall war um eine
generelle immunisierung
umzusetzen die bevölkerung zu schützen
und das ergänzend dazu
in dieser vereinbarung vorgesehen haben
verpflichtende maßnahmen beim impfen um
zu setzen auf bundesrechtliche basis
nach einem gutachterverfahren wo wir
nicht nur alle politischen parteien und
sozialpartner sondern auch kräfte der
zivilgesellschaft mit einbeziehen wollen
um zu einer bundesgesetzlichen lösung zu
kommen die verpflichtende maßnahmen im
bereich hilfen vorsieht wir sind
gemeinsam zur auffassung gelangt trotz
langer skepsis die fehler von uns
geteilt haben dass das ein wirksames
instrument ist menschen auch zum impfen
zu motivieren und zu verhindern dass
eine fünfte welle auf uns zukommt aber
all das was wir beim impfen umsetzen ist
uns bewusst hilft uns nicht in den
nächsten tagen einen impfschutz
aufzubauen das dauert wenn man mit der
ersten dosis beginnt dauert das wochen
und diese zeit haben wir nicht
deshalb haben wir in dieser vereinbarung
vorgesehen über die parteigrenzen hinweg
über die bundesländergrenzen hinweg dass
wir in solidarität zu den bundesländern
salzburg und oberösterreich
gleiche einschränkungen
bundeseinheitlich regeln und diese
maßnahmen auch gemeinsam tragen werden
20 tage hindurch
mit der notwendigkeit die er auch jetzt
schon besteht dass noch zehn tagen im
hauptausschuss des nationalrates über
diese maßnahmen gefunden werden muss da
auch eine möglichkeit einer evaluierung
besteht aber prinzipiell wir an diesen
20 tagen orientiert sind
anschließend während diese maßnahmen für
ungeimpfte weiter bestehen denn auch
jetzt gibt es ja schon einschränkende
maßnahmen für ungeimpfte wir wollen
damit deutlich machen dass wir jene die
bereit sind sich selbst zu schützen mit
einer impfung aber auch die anderen die
gesellschaft mithelfen zu schützen dass
es hier dann auch vorteile geben soll im
zugang auch zu allen wirtschaftlichen
und gesellschaftlichen
möglichkeiten und von daher sehen wir
diese solidarität mit den beiden
bundesländern salzburg und
oberösterreich aus verschiedenen gründen
für ganz wichtig zum einen weil ich
immer der auffassung war es ist in
dieser krise gut wenn wir
bundeseinheitliche regelungen treffen
und diese gemeinsam tragen aber auch aus
dem grund heraus dass wir einen
bundesländern kommunizierende gefäße
sind und wenn es zu einer überlastung in
spitälern in einem bundesland kommt sind
wir so solidarisch immer gewesen
zwischen den bundesländern dass wir uns
auch um patientinnen und patienten
kümmern die nicht aus dem eigenen
bundesland stammen aber das stößt an die
grenzen wenn dann wie in einem
dominoeffekt die kapazitäten in allen
bundesländern an das ende gelangen also
von daher ist es wichtig die
ernsthaftigkeit dieser situation nicht
nur zu erkennen sondern auch die
verantwortung in der politik
wahrzunehmen zu führen auch unpopuläre
maßnahmen zu setzen und wir alle wissen
wir wären kein schönheitspreis bekommen
und es wird viel kritik geben das war
aber bereit sind diese kritik auf uns zu
nehmen um die gesundheit und das leben
von menschen zu retten um zu sichern das
sehen wir in unserer verantwortung und
das ist wichtiger als viele andere
begleiterscheinungen die
selbstverständlich auftreten werden
natürlich ist es so dass in der
vorweihnachtszeit wo viele branchen
besonders damit gerechnet haben ihre
umsätze zu machen dass das eine
einschneidende maßnahme ist und das wird
auch verbunden sein das haben wir auch
besprochen da quittiert dass es auch
entsprechende wirtschaftshilfen geben
wird aber wir gehen davon aus dass nach
diesen maßnahmen die wir bis 13 dezember
ausrichten wollen dass es noch die
möglichkeit gibt
auch all das was man wirtschaftlich
familiär persönlich umsetzen will vor
der weihnachtszeit dass das noch möglich
sein wird von daher denke ich ist das
ein wichtiger schritt den wir gemeinsam
in dieser vereinbarung festgelegt haben
den wir bereits sind auch gemeinsam zu
tragen auch entgegen aller
kritikpunkte die jetzt an uns gerichtet
sein werden und von daher herr
landeshauptmann platter günther kann man
sagen war dieses treffens ist ja ein
historisches